you literally should pray to never win
the lottery it would be the most amazing
and most terrible day of your life
because how are you going to have a
better day than that even though we
might want our goals and accomplishments
to arrive immediately maybe a smarter
strategy is to actually stretch out the
achievement of our dreams we shouldn't
wish for overnight success because we
would then need to be able to beat it
pretty soon or else we're going to feel
like we're declining let's say that you
got a pay rise and you were able to
afford your dream car instead of going
from Total box to ultimate car that
you've ever wanted you have the
opportunity to chunk that up maybe you
could go halfway and take a bunch of
satisfaction from that because once
you've got the dream car what is there
after that if you have the opportunity
of making a couple of small jumps in
between that aren't the massive leap to
the very top I think that you can
stretch out that sense of progression
and what you want is to always continue
this very nice sort of slow steady ramp
up and then you can just flatten out
toward the end of your life trajectory
is more important than position